[Music]
from Germany just send them straight out
the door okay thanks a lot
let's go upstairs welcome to Miami
[Music]
so just coming from well we have the
head of we have the head of VP of retail
and I think one of the marketing people
are bringing a one of a kind and that
there's only one prototype
I saw it recently when they were touring
the world with and I said that would be
a fantastic pan for me to write my shark
tangles with and they said well it
doesn't exist if you only have one I
said well that's the one I'll use so he
went through a long discussion about it
and they came to an agreement and so I'm
going to be lent it for a few months and
then I'd like to purchase it whenever if
it ever gets into production but it's a
beautiful pen we're going to see it when
they arrived it's you know it's a very
coveted pieces the only one in the world
and so let's look at it together very
cool
I will fly with it to LA I'll write down
my offers
I love pants I got a big pen collection
or structure that's it are we gonna do
the dependent thing up here right yeah I
think it would just sit there ready for
a flight in before a lottery also
they're gonna be filling for 50 minutes
and we gotta get to the handoff of the
item our peak at 11:59 code 11:59 the
first one of its kind in America I'm
buying them today at about two o'clock
when a huge watch collector I only make
good investments in watches I try and
find very rare pieces and no one else
have like this watch you're going to see
it later
extraordinary piece they've been
designing this thing since the 70s lot
of controversy about this watch you know
the key is when the original AP Royal up
came out that's an AP Royal oh this
octagon shape was was poo-pooed by the
critics they didn't like it it was not
well-received decades later it's one of
the most coveted watches on earth I
think the same thing is happening right
now with the 11:59 the Codel up 59 very
controversial just was introduced in
Switzerland a couple of months ago half
the crowd hated it half the crowd loved
it exactly what happened in 1972 I
stepped up and said I'll buy it because
I know there's a lot of controversy
around a new design and that's what I'm
betting on I'm betting if this will
become one of those coveted pieces in 20
years and I long reversed one
[Music]
it already has a ribbon on that is a
1970s circa moon watch from Omega very
rare beautiful piece you want that 79
model is after that they start using
plastic pieces which I don't like so
fine now oh yeah
this little puppy that this beautiful
Rolex
clasp is going to be featured on Shark
Tank as well so but we need to put on it
this is a really rare sub marinus is a
diving watch with a special release
valve but with red type so very hard to
get but I want the whole band to be red
now they don't make this in a stock so
I've been waiting six months for one of
them to be manufactured in Switzerland
to be put on this watch today so when we
meet Benjamin the drop would be it'll be
the only mounting ever in the world this
will be the only watch with a red band
they look at this integration you see
what matters about rubber B is this
integration where it meets the case is
seamless there's no space it looks like
this band was made for the watch because
it was this is extremely difficult to do
in a manufacturing process that's why I
only whose rubber B isn't that beautiful
gorgeous I mean that has a beautiful
balance to it what a watch so when did
you meet rubber B I started doing
research about bands and we went through
a lot of work and a lot of iterations to
decide which company to go with because
I'd used other companies and I didn't
like any of the stuff they did so I met
them here I asked to meet the CEO when I
do visit of the company I want to meet
the head guy I want to start at the top
tell him about our relationship the
relationship
build over the years to come all the
work I'm going to be doing with them and
I really care about my watches so once
we met he understood my mission
we formed a relationship he's the only
company I use for my red bands now in
the case of the watch we're going to see
later I explained what I wanted to do
with Adam RP ket they said no no we will
go around the world to find the right
letter for you will match the leather we
will make a one-of-a-kind watch for you
know I like that too
that's really cool so this code would
11:59 we're going to see together is the
only one of a kind in the world that has
a red band on that's gonna make the
watch if even more valuable young IO
Calle so looking at the comments in
YouTube unless I not everybody loves it
I don't care you have to be bold right
this and this one opinion is so what's
the deal with the red band like why red
you know is it to fly your Canadian
colors is it because it's a power color
no snow I wear I wear black suits and
red and black this is the beginning of
time have been a beautiful contrast so I
want to have that accoutrement I want
that red flash that jeunesse a quoi and
I just let the caller slip oh he's got
the red band on that's why I do it it's
beautiful now to do it right is very
hard so you want to match your things
together cufflinks have to be perfect
the pan has to be right
that's why we're meeting with mall blah
I want the perfect pin to match with
this new coat 11:59 I've searched the
world there's only one pen in the world
that'll do it it's coming here today the
handoff they flew over from Germany
we're gonna meet for a few minutes boom
they're gonna get back on the plane but
I'll have the only one of its kind and
what a fantastic union that'll be the
pan the links the watch the suit the tie
the tie pin they all come together and
that's what makes me mr. money there's
only one mr. wonderful that's what
[Music]
now we've got them on multi I have
brought some of my mobile pieces with me
because I'm trying to match the Pens
with the watches how is this going to
work which pan which watch these are all
highly collectible watches this is from
the Beatle series this is from James
Dean Virginia Woolf
Marilyn Monroe this is a very classic
design so the mobile all people are
gonna bring you weather unique pen
you're going to see it for the first
time it's a one-of-a-kind one-of-a-kind
I love those I look at spills off my
knee it's one of a kind so for the
purists let's go back to the watch for
the purists who say you ruining that
beautiful rule actually ruling ruining
that beautiful AP by taking off the
original band what do you say about
putting you know these alternative bands
on a beam you know if you want to
stylize a watch and I understand the
purists point I totally understand that
but I don't agree I keep the original
band with the case and the papers as I
showed as a collector but my point is if
I want to make an accoutrement something
unique to my collection I've got to do
this and for me it's the red band and I
get my everybody's you know putting
their point of view up but look at the
controversy that's part of the whole
idea is to be controversial and make a
statement and look I get people writing
even thousands of emails to people
saying oh you can't put a red band on
that watch well I can in fact I even
research to the extent on this ap this
called the jumbo extremely rare watch I
have actually got the links made by Adam
RP cats and I'm go get them show them to
you that we're going to use to integrate
the red band so it's going to be a
perfect integration so AP endorses my
integration knowing that I'm a collector
[Music]
I mean I carry a bunch because I'm
always shooting television and I use
different pens for different this is
actually one of my favorite Virginia and
the disease
yeah the Ariat agent I also like this
one just for the the shape of it the
Marilyn Monroe but you know people are
always asking me what is that what is
that I mean you guys have done a really
good job and you have your Beados
collection yeah I lost this for two days
and I was freaking out
I left it in another city I was in three
cities in one day this is a fantastic
television watch I it's so distinctive
and I will use it for a couple of the
episodes because it's so interesting
you know when people are always a tree
going back to India and you also made a
special link for for the Beatles you did
most of our writing instruments that we
have it's a limited edition collection
we make the ink that's a special color
to go with the rest you know it's a
great idea so it complements I ended
before heritage is very nice yeah
because as you said that we created is a
gamble but it was originally this parent
existed in the forest right yeah I think
I find about it's so functional they
like this is one of my favorites as well
you get to know the Pens after work with
them for almost a year so we have
different person completely and just
depends on the mood that you're in that
you want to write with that exerting it
gentlemen
lately I've been really enjoying this
because it's also a great television
watch and it's such a bowl to stay on up
beautiful matches the red man's gonna
give them the red a tree and if you had
a yeah I'm going to
that's definitely do that I want to show
you something I just won this year I
just received it today
reality TV ability yeah two million
folks around the world
I'm very mother's I've got four Emmys
but this one I really care about as you
should be amazing so let's see some
fantastic and the moment I remember it
was when I looked at the collection that
day this is the one that really stood
out to you because I think it's a very
functional design it's not so crazy that
you know it's too striking but it's a
perfect blend when you touch a piece
like this you have to wear gloves
there's no question about yes ah writing
instruments yes writing is we know I go
to them a pen my guys all the marks
myself speaking about and they can keep
now this is the only one in the world
right now correct yes
well how do we go
but limited to 88 pieces 88 and I have
my eye on number 13 as you incur a
concession good news I got it you got it
when will I actually Aniki when will it
will be ready to September yes that's
what we are pushing oh yeah look at that
isn't that beautiful
I mean it's it's it's going to look
gorgeous on set it was in question
because it just reflects light so
beautifully the craftsmanship that's
with this rating instrument and as you
just showed that neighbor yeah you have
the dominant yeah that is absolutely
spectacular I love that my goodness I
will course take care of it there's no
question about it
I'm sure now thank wise is there a
mobile all boo teak in Rodeo Drive in LA
yes InBev seminar Center okay because I
have to pick up some ink and I can't fly
with it no you can't um if you'd like if
you provide me with the address where
you're going to be I'll have something
FedEx there that was the greatest singer
okay so take the address after yeah
that'd be great
so I have some ink there and I'll start
writing with a lot of Wednesday very
glad to come to say yeah oh just do the
retail value of that writing instrument
is this particular is thirty four
thousand five hundred not inexpensive
but well worth it when they'll only be
eighty eight of them in the world why 88
what's the reason for eighty ninety
number yeah I think thirteen silence
[Music]
[Music]
subscribe to my channel you know what
happens you'll be dead to me
[Music]